the unique visual styles composed by our
next nominees were achieved by creative
use of formats as varied as the stories
they capture from a soft and subtle love
story shot on super 16 millimeter films
to a larger-than-life action thriller
shot in the widescreen 70 millimeter
format not used since the 1960s here are
the nominees for achievement in
cinematography the hateful eight Robert
Richardson Carol deadlock Sicario Roger
Deakins Mad Max fury road John Hsu the
revenant Emmanuel Lubezki and the Oscar
goes to a Manuel Levesque key
this is the third consecutive Oscar win
for Emmanuel Lubezki
last year in this category for Birdman
here's a total of eight
Academy thank you so much this is
incredible I want to share it with the
cast and crew especially with my
compadre mr. Anaya to to your passion
Alejandro and I want to share this also
with Leon Tom for their great
performance all the producers and New
Regency and Fox for all the freedom and
the support my wife Lauren Ally Danny I
love you so much Daniela happy birthday
to my parents my friends and to all the
cinematographers that were nominated
with me I admire you so much I love your
work and the hand rope thank you so much